[Music]
more than 1,000 Fiat Cinquecento are
being put through their paces here on
the Italian Riviera each summer you can
see the most eye-catching examples from
around the world here in Garland ah this
model dates from 1969 there are plenty
of bends in the road here for Alberto
Puccini driving this car it's always
it's not the fun it's a special feeling
because it's like a time travel I will
say it's really all the style of wage
drive it's a mixer now you don't get
with the normal or going cars of the
times so this is really completely
different and this is the spirit of
driving a Fiat Cinquecento
the cinquecento the Fiat 500 is being
fitted with a whole range of events the
annual meet is organized by the Fiat 500
club italia which has more than 20,000
members around the world and this year
fans from far and wide are marking the
60th anniversary of this iconic small
car many of them have been here before
wait time here 10 years ago because we
drive a little car like this right
around the world from Vladivostok all
the way to Garland er and then all the
way to Anchorage in Alaska we're all
crazy about this car just look that's
the Fiat 500 bug
this cute car is remarkable because in
mechanical terms it is so
straightforward powered by just 13
horsepower vintage Fiat 500s like this
also don't have anything like power
steering and changing gears requires
practice when you downshift it's gonna
be like that
because you play twice over the clutter
you get to push the throttle the gearbox
is not synch so you get to do that you
can feel how's the life some years ago
it's an important thing to feel and
taste
Albert Albert Jeanne also calls in at
the Fiat 500 club's museum in Garland
Carlo Jelena is one of the rally
organizers and he has created an
exhibition here about the history of the
car which helped change Italian society
its introduction in 1957 marked the
beginning of rural mobility
four people a family with kids and the
whole kitten caboodle could travel
around Italy in relative comfort chain
thought was the first opportunity for
the two Italians to pass from the
scooter to a real car and that car was
designed by Don Teja cosa the engineer
had already created its predecessor the
tapa lino but got his big break in 1957
with a Fiat 500 nova a new Cinquecento
was launched by joe cosa successors in
1991 but wasn't too popular
only when Fiat brought out a retro model
in 2007 did sales pick up but at the car
meet in Garland a-- they're all fans of
the original and it's timeless design I
can't follow a Ferrari with my car
[ __ ] nuts in the city the kids will
come and look at this car that's
something in the kid's mind i never been
able to understand what i see when i
look at - because it's something a
bitter smiling i don't know i find out
something smiling in the face of that
car in u.s. i when we were driving there
they had never seen these and look at
them and they'll wave and smile it's
just it is a car that brings out
happiness in everybody
[Music]
for many participants one of the
highlights is cruising through the
countryside on the linger e'en coast
with a soft top down and at a leisurely
pace since the car has a top speed of 85
kilometers per hour
our speed is almost limited but anyway
we can really feel the sky up over there
with aza the countryside
that's Fiat Cinquecento and that's Italy
the procession of classic Cinquecento
spaces through one village after another
after a short rest stop the journey
continues a journey back in time to the
1960s when la dolce vita was alive and
well
[Music]
you